more than a few legendary actors have
played the clown prince of crime but
even among them jared leto's joker has
walked a long strange path
we are here to explain the character's
journey from suicide squad to the snyder
cut
in justin mark's original draft of the
suicide squad screenplay the joker
doesn't actually appear at all
david ayer's revisions later added the
joker as a fundamental element of the
story
leto himself wasn't even the first
choice for the character ryan gosling
had originally been approached for the
role
similarly the joker's longtime love
interest harley quinn came close to
being played by cara delevingne before
she snagged the role of the enchantress
instead
up to the casting announcement letto
played coy believe it or not he had
originally looked into playing the
titular character in doctor strange but
marvel wanted a bigger star for the role
to sell a lesser-known character to
audiences
this encouraged lotto to pursue warner
brothers who jumped at the chance to
cast the academy award-winning performer
in such an iconic role
the rest is history official set photos
of letto's joker were released in april
2015
to mixed reception the photos show the
actors sporting joker's
short green locks pale complexion and
wild grin unfortunately the photos also
showed another notable set of features
however which were received with less
enthusiasm
this joker sports metal grills over his
top and bottom rows of teeth and
a slew of tattoos among his many tattoos
are massive grins
spread across his forearm and hand a
skull and a jester hat on his chest
dozens of iterations of hahaha down his
arm and the word
damaged written in cursive across his
forehead one thing was clear
this joker was an entirely new creation
joker's hahaha tattoos nod at some
heavily hinted backstory from 2016's
batman vs superman dawn of justice
in which a robin costume defaced by
yellow letters spelling out hahaha
is glimpsed among batman's things in the
bat cave knowing batman
it's likely on display as a solemn
reminder of his failure to protect robin
who is implied to have died at the
joker's hand
in snyder's take on the dceu in an
interview with entertainment weekly ayer
further explained the joker's look and
its connection to batman
joker killed robin and batman basically
smashes his teeth out and locks him up
in arkham asylum
it's in the asylum where joker would
have done the damaged tattoo as
a message to batman saying you've
damaged me i was so beautiful before and
now you've destroyed my face
that's where the grill comes from
however ayer has come to have
reservations about the creative choice
when asked about the decision in 2018 he
replied
yes i have to fall on that sword it was
one step too far
leto's behavior on the suicide squad set
became the subject of much speculation
and controversy
rumors circulated about the gifts he
allegedly sent to various members of the
cast
adam beech who played slipknot told e
that he sent the entire cast a dead hog
in addition to other strange items he
sent margot robbie a nice love letter
with a black box with a rat
in it a live rat the rat initially
freaked out robbie but she eventually
bonded with the animal and named him rat
rat
these antics gave letto a curious
reputation it was even falsely rumored
that letto sent a dead rat to his
co-stars likely the result of loose
public memory of the very much alive rat
gift
suicide squad was met with overwhelming
critical derision upon release with
leto's joker
acting as something of a flashpoint of
serious disdain as
insider critic jacob shamsian put it
letto's version is a gangster who has a
clown makeup fetish he doesn't have any
dastardly plans or even does anything
particularly clever he's just a really
angry dude who probably regrets his
tattoos
other critics eviscerated the film's
portrayal of the joker quinn
relationship as a facile romanticization
of abuse
all in all critics and moviegoers ripped
leto's joker apart
suicide squad's joker became something
of a symbol of the dceu's failures
i am not someone who is loved
i'm an idea for all the sound and fury
kicked up over the joker's role in
suicide squad the final cut of the film
actually deprives him of any real
spotlight the joker is in fact barely in
the movie
at all leto expressed significant
surprise and was clearly upset with the
exclusion
when asked by ign if he was upset about
the scenes that were cut he responded
were there any scenes that didn't get
cut i'm asking you were there any that
didn't get cut
there were so many scenes that got cut
from the movie i couldn't even start
i think that the joker we did a lot of
experimentation on the set we explored a
lot there's so much that we shot that's
not in the film
for his part ayer also expressed regrets
about the joker being so tangential to
the story
as he noted wish i had a time machine
i'd make joker the main villain and
engineer
a more grounded story in august 2017 it
was announced that a joker and harley
quinn movie was headed to the silver
screen
the proposed dc romance was said to be a
criminal love story memorably described
by one source as when harry met sally on
benzedrine
it was intended to enter production
after the then planned suicide squad
sequel wrapped up but of course things
did not work out that way
as of this video while the film is still
on leto's imdb page
it is heavily rumored to have been
cancelled this speculation combined with
margot robbie's dismissal of the harley
joker relationship
and birds of parade's definitive ending
of it all signal that this film is
extremely
unlikely to happen in june 2018 it was
announced that leto was going to star in
a solo joker outing
at the time rumors were also swirling
regarding two proposed approaches to the
dc eu that could theoretically exist
simultaneously
one slate of movies would maintain
established continuity while the other
would do its own thing
allowing filmmakers to put their own
unique stamp on these iconic characters
at this point both letto's joker film
and the todd phillips helmed joker movie
released in 2019 were reportedly in
development
philip's film was reported to be part of
the branch of dc movies that would be
distinct from the dceu's continuity
however lettuce joker did not come to
fruition at
all as was initially planned instead dc
moved on from dceu continuity entirely
in a soft reboot of sorts harley quinn
has carried forward through birds of
prey and
into james gunn's the suicide squad but
she has done so without her puddin
in effect leto's solo joker outing has
been left in permanent limbo with leto
reportedly feeling strung along by empty
promises as initial plans for the dceu
were abandoned in light of the success
of standalone movies like joker
so too was letto's joker tossed on the
scrap heap of cinematic history
2017's justice league does not include
his interpretation of the character at
all
birds of prey torches the joker harley
relationship without a single leto
appearance
matt reeves batman films occur far
outside the previously established dc
continuity
james gunn's reboot the suicide squad
tells a new story that is wholly
separate from the first
suicide squad film despite initial
promises that joaquin phoenix's turn as
the joker would not
impede leto's own standalone film
reports indicate that leto was unhappy
to learn of the competing film
allegedly leto complained heavily to his
agents at caa
and asked his music manager irving azov
to call the head of warner's parent
company in the hopes of ending philip's
film
leto's camp denies these claims while
azov who has since parted ways with leto
offered no comment
sources told the hollywood reporter that
leto felt his agents should have stuck
up more fiercely for his take on the
joker
fought philip's movie more adamantly and
told him about the competing project
sooner leto has since left caa for wme
but his team claims the alternate joker
adaptation had no role in the decision
one unnamed source close to the
situation declared letto's joker to be
effectively dead
asking how do you play the joker you
established following phoenix it kind of
ends as joker run
2017's justice league produced an outcry
among fans they argued that director
zack snyder who left the project
following a family tragedy should be
allowed to re-cut and release the film
to reflect his original directorial
vision
online fan campaigns called for warner
executives to release the snyder cut a
cry that was eventually bolstered by the
film's own stars
just when it seemed that leto's future
in the dc films was all but done
a surprising thing happened in may 2020
warner brothers announced that the
snyder cut was real
and that they would be releasing it on
the hbo max streaming platform in 2021
among all the changes and additions the
snyder cut makes to justice league is a
post-apocalyptic future scene that
includes a brand new version of leto's
joker
the scene envisions a dystopic dc
universe where beloved characters have
been lost and the world is ruled by a
tyrant
our heroes are in such disarray they
have to work with traditional villains
villains like leto's joker back in the
dc picture at last
that the joker is part of zack snyder's
justice league is surprising enough
even more jaw dropping is the fact that
this joker is entirely and fully
redesigned
gone are the tattoos the short hair and
the visible grill
instead we find an apocalypse weary
future joker with a pained laugh
long hair and multiple scars he's no
longer dressed as a flashy gangster
instead wearing long threadbare clothing
which makes sense as his criminal empire
would have had to crumble in such a
wasteland
photos released in the lead-up to the
debut of zack snyder's justice league
signaled this change in design
they reveal a menacing weary much more
frightening version of the character
than the neon criminal we saw in 2016.
these aesthetic changes are meant to
reflect changes in the character's
circumstances
as letto put it in an interview with
stephen colbert suicide squad joker and
snyder joker are some years apart
well i think it's an evolution um you
know
there's some years apart and you know
certainly different directors
the new look was met with a largely
positive reception especially when
contrasted against the reception of the
suicide squad design
when the february 14th trailer for zack
snyder's justice league premiered fans
celebrated the new dark side footage
enhanced battle sequences and the brand
new look for dc villain
steppenwolf another interesting addition
also made its debut
a scene between ben affleck's batman and
jared leto's joker glimpsed at the tail
end of the trailer his back turned
towards the camera the joker mutters
we live in a society where honor
is a distant memory isn't that right
that particular scene was written in
quarantine by snyder who coaxed a
hesitant letter into returning to the
character for the project the scene was
filmed in three days with affleck and
leto shooting in separate locations due
to schedule constraints
the we live in a society line was
actually ad-libbed by letto as he told
stephen colbert it was
an ad-lib that i threw out on the day
shooting it ended up in the trailer and
then
kind of went viral as momentum built
towards the release of zack snyder's
justice league
some fans began to advocate for the
release of an aircut of suicide squad
as david ayer has repeatedly insisted
the suicide squad that hit theaters
diverges heavily from his intended
vision
according to ayer the first 40 minutes
of the film were cut the film was also
supposed to tie heavily into justice
league an approach that was abandoned
however don't get your hopes up that the
snyder cut might lead to ayer getting
his own prestige re-edit
warner media studios ceo ann sarnoff has
stated bluntly
we won't be developing david ayer's cut
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite comic book heroes and villains
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]